the orp dragon law is probably the most
prestigious skin in cs go
factory new dragon laws can fetch
anywhere between ten thousand and two
hundred thousand
dollars players and collectors just go
absolutely nuts for this thing
[Music]
but why well let's go back the dragon
law orb was released in 2014 and from
the get-go it was clearly a cut above it
was the first skin that had that status
of like shock factor almost like a
lamborghini
its popularity quickly skyrocketed and
trying to get one was hard it didn't
help that pros
adored the skin
[Music]
and that scarcity just spread more
interest in the skin and when cobble was
finally removed from the matte pool in
2018 the supply of souvenir dragon laws
was cut and if you're thinking of
getting one well estimates point to a
0.02
chance of opening one from a case that
now costs over six hundred dollars